QZ
the act is the true crime story of Gypsy
Rose Blanchard who is currently serving
a ten year sentence for plotting the
murder of her mother Dee Dee's Gypsy
Rose Blanchard how do you plead
gypsy story was made famous in the HBO
documentary mommy dead and Dearest for
years gypsy was abused by her mom who
convinced her that she was extremely
sick when she wasn't what illnesses did
your mom say that you had um asthma
epilepsy hearing impaired vision
impaired fed with the feeding too
paralyzed from the waist down in the
hulu drama Patricia Arquette plays the
mom and Joey King the daughter her
mother had Munchausen by proxy and just
for years kept gypsy prisoner in a
wheelchair you know how to have
operations she didn't mean she had a
feeding tube and she could swallow fine
and it was just just so many years of
Lies and imprisonment you've already
gone to the ER six times this year
dee dee believes all this is necessary
like she kind of thinks she's smarter
than the doctors so she really does
think these things that her daughter
does need these things Marcia Gay Harden
played dee dee in a Lifetime movie about
the case this version is a series which
shows Dee Dee pumping her daughter full
of drugs shaving her head to make it
look like she was a cancer patient look
like a girl in one of the main things
was how you really fully immerse
yourself in this role and you fully
commit and that you are unrecognizable
physical transformation I shaved my head
we have gypsies glasses I'm very good
replica and I wear fake teeth there's
like four stages of fake teeth Dede was
stabbed to death by gypsies boyfriend
and the twisted real-life story became
weirder
her family flushed her own ashes down
the toilet I mean that's very intense
[Music]